all right there's something really
strange going on with twitch
people are getting banned for some
pretty ridiculous reasons and for some
considerable amounts of time
what's even stranger about this though
is that twitch keeps admitting that they
made a mistake with the bands and
reneging on them over and over again
i spoke to the streamers whose
livelihoods are being ruined by twitch's
erratic banhammer
to try and figure out what exactly is
going on
all right same old twitch same old
request that i have for you guys
if you want to make sure you never miss
a video here on the score esports or on
donate me just like this
then make sure you are subscribed have
you done it
yeah all done good great for anyone not
living under a rock
you'll know that when twitch bans a big
name on their platform
it's a big deal now with some of them
it's pretty obvious why twitch dropped
the banhammer
this is so insane
america deserve 911 dude i'm saying it
while with others we're not entirely
sure what happened
and then have that taken away from you
and to not know why
and to not know anything about it not to
be told nothing
boom taken grabbed everything we built
and when other
less severe permabans happened like with
the case of airsoft fatty
it felt like twitch were beginning to
take bans more seriously
the fact that this isn't bigger news is
indicative of a growing trend on the
platform
the days of twitch using permanent bands
as a last resort
are gone and so could be the wild west
version of twitch
that once used them so sparingly some of
twitch's rules are clear as day
violence hate speech threats doxing
spam scams and sexually explicit content
are a big no-no everyone knows that but
in the last few months smaller streamers
have been getting banned for what i can
only describe
as really weird reasons and it's
happening at an accelerated rate
right now it may only be affecting a
handful of smaller streamers but it does
seem like the cases are trending upwards
seriously something is going on with
twitch's band system
see prior to twitch's huts of meta bands
on the platform weren't exactly a rare
thing
but it wasn't an everyday thing either
for those who missed it the hot tub meta
was an influx of streamers in bathing
suits just
splashing around in inflatable pools it
was everywhere
and some people felt like twitch wasn't
coming down hard enough on what they saw
as sexually explicit content jump
forward to now and it feels like the
frequency and opaque nature of twitch
banning streamers
is peaking in a way it seems like it
happens constantly now perhaps they felt
pressured to enforce their own rules but
the result over the past while
has been more strange bands more
mistaken bands and an overall lack of
communication from twitch
take the case of feinberg he's a popular
minecraft speedrunner who made a name
for himself back in may
for knocking the minecraft fsg speedrun
record
down to just five minutes and 42 seconds
but his joy didn't last too long because
less than a month later
feinberg tweeted out a cry for help to
twitch support
hi twitch support day two of me being
unfairly suspended on my alternate
account
feinberg sucks for making fun of myself
i'll delete the account or change the
name i don't care
i stream full time and i will break
terms of service if i use my main
account
it appeared that feinberg had broken the
rules because his old account feinberg
sucks have been unfairly poking fun
at himself i spoke to feinberg about
receiving that strange email from twitch
and stream i'd like get ready for bed on
my phone get an email
like gmail so i click on the
notification and it's like your twitch
account feinberg sucks has been
infinitely suspended i was like what did
i do
i was like this is this is not good so i
open the email
it's like for a name and i was like [ __ ]
when they finally got back to him
the clarification wasn't all that clear
they simply unsuspended his account and
changed his name
to not feinberg kappa no apology
no explanation nothing just not feinberg
kappa the whole thing had echoes of a
similar case with george not
found a streamer whose account was
banned for harassment via username the
offending name in question was this is
not george not found literally just a
play on his usual name
but somehow twitch found this to be
harassment
of himself now in feinberg's case he
might have been banned because feinberg
sucks contains the word sucks which
might be on their list of banned words
for user names
the thing is though i found a twitch
account that's
literally just called sucks that's it
that's the
entire username so it can't really be
sucks that's the problem here
the only thing i can think of is that
maybe like someone new found my stream
like maybe someone from my youtube or
just someone who didn't know it was
me through twitch discoverability or
whatever and then was like okay this is
like this guy's like making fun of
feinberg and then they reported me
and then twitch also didn't know that it
was me it was also the fact that it was
an indefinite ban not a warning
not a two-week ban just a straight-up
indefinite ban
right off the bat he was scared to
stream on his main account even though
it wasn't banned in case he was seen as
trying to dodge the ban
essentially he felt like his streaming
career was over
alright now let's talk about someone
else who had an indefinite ban
velvet now you might have heard this
story she's a south korean youtuber
who shares travel vlogs with her
followers and also promotes her
only fans account on twitter now
obviously only fans and twitch have a
completely different set of rules
and velvet was completely aware of
twitch's terms of service when she
started streaming on the platform
following the guidelines to a t that's
why she was shocked when she was hit
with an
indefinite ban in may 2019 for sexually
suggestive content
at the time like i was unable to get a
chance to speak with any twitch staff
you know like to talk about like
specific reason why i got banned
and how i can solve the problem because
like when i look at other channels on
just chatting
like other people like other girls
on there like was partnered with twitch
they were doing the same thing or even
work even more like sexually suggestive
thing and they were fine you only have
to look at the whole heart of meta to
see how twitch's definition
of sexually suggested content can be
loose at best
twitch's head of creator development dj
wheat addressed all of this in an
official stream
so hot tub meta our nudity and attire
policy
does allow bathing suits in an
appropriate context
and hot tubs do fall under
that criteria however what has not
changed is the sexually suggestive
and explicit content is not allowed
under the guidelines
under the tos and twitch will take
action
when that is reported to us
twitch eventually created a whole new
category for hot tub streams
and also published a lengthy blog post
to explain their decision making
we covered the whole hot tub meta
controversy on this show when it
happened
it's hard to pinpoint exactly where this
all started
but since late last year hot tubs have
been building a following
and so is the controversy that's come
with it from exo aerial to amaranth
mia malkova to kiara kitty who's also
been
banned for some hot tubs have come to
dominate the front page of twitch
[ __ ] hot tub streams have gotten so
popular even
v-tubers are getting in on the action
in velvet's case though she even shared
images of the outfits that she was
wearing during her stream to show people
that there was no sexual suggestion
going on now this might have been the
end of the story
but four months later twitch reached out
and admitted that they have made a
mistake
but it gets even more insane velvet was
banned again for what twitch says
was use of racial slurs velvet says that
never happened
and that twitch never responded when she
asked them to specify
they did eventually reply only to tell
her that
once again they have made a mistake
while all of this was going on velvet
decided to apply to become a twitch
partner
she felt that if she became a partner
she wouldn't have to put up with these
random bands every few months
and would have a direct line with twitch
to talk to them about these things
but get this twitch said that to become
a partner
velvet had to have a clean record of no
bans for the past
three months she didn't have that she
didn't have that
because twitch kept mistakenly banning
her
velvet continued streaming for a few
months but guess what happened
in april 2020 velvet was banned
again for the same sexually suggestive
reason
with no specification from twitch and no
ability to talk to them
she didn't have to wait long for another
email this time where
once again you guessed it twitch
admitted that the whole thing was their
mistake
there's no happy ending for velvet yet
she's currently banned
it's been over a year now and she's had
to move all of her streaming
to youtube losing all of the work that
she put into twitch and the income that
came with it
and lastly there's the case of john
zerka he's been a controversial figure
on twitch for the past couple of years
and quickly shot to fame as people
discussed whether he was a genius
or just a troll in march 2021 john
zurker was banned from twitch for what
was initially an
unknown reason the following month he
shared that it was allegedly because he
clicked on a photo of a girl in a bikini
on stream for too long
adding i thought this would be harmless
because girls literally blow up swimming
pools in their living rooms and pose
sexually
bounce on a floaty for millions of
dollars on twitch
after two months of him being in the
dark he shared an email from twitch
in which they said they were reversing
the ban and that it was their mistake
so once again we have a case of a
streamer being banned for a considerable
amount of time
enough to really affect their livelihood
by mistake
another thing that john cerca and velvet
have in common is that they both talked
about the hypocrisy from twitch when it
comes to these bands
for example when twitch streamer
amaranth was banned for licking a
microphone
during an asmr stream she was banned for
just three days
other streamers like the ones we've
talked about in this video have had to
face
months of waiting in the dark until they
eventually find out
that it was all just twitch's mistake
and some of them don't even get that
they're still waiting there's a year's
old sense of frustration now in the
twitch community
by those who feel that it's one rule for
the big partnered streamers and another
rule for the little guys
the question is can they fix these
opaque rules and mistaken bans
and given just how many cases have come
up recently
do they even want to perform
it's a big deal it's a big deal
the thing is
don't do that
the funny thing is if this video was in
the uk this this next word that i'm
going to say will get bleeped out but
it's not going to get bleeped out
[ __ ] [ __ ] now now
go and watch go watch any british
company like on youtube they will not
let you say [ __ ]
and here like it's not being bleeped out
it's fine
it's fine